hello wall and yes I'm still being held
captive in California and yes I'm not
wearing any pants but some pretty cool
news today because this is the day I
found out that Michael Bay actually
agrees with me he has come out and said
Transformers Revenge of the Fallen was
crap and we all knew it was crap and
Shia LaBeouf came out and said it was
crap but they said it was crap for like
two different reasons Michael Bay said
it was because of the writers strike
Shia LaBeouf said it was because Michael
Bay aimed too high and tried to make it
too much and too much was just horrible
either case it's always neat to see a
guy admit his faults especially when his
faults were what drove me to do this yes
summer of 2009 I saw transformers 2 I
hated it I got on camera in the first
words I ever spoke on YouTube were
transformers - uh yeah um is there
anyone out there who hasn't been raped
as bad as I have and now here we are so
the whole Michael Bay and transformers
thing are really monumental to me and
yeah I've gotten a lot of hate because I
hate transformers too but at this point
the director of the movie agrees with me
so in the words of the Joker I'm not a
monster just ahead of the curve and do I
believe he actually believes the movies
crap I think he's known it was crap for
a long time he had to have seen
screenings of the movie like the final
cut of the movie and he had to have seen
it before we saw it he had to have known
it was crap when he saw it otherwise it
took him a year and a half to realize it
probably not I personally think he's
just saying this because he knows that a
lot of people out there think it was
crap they're not gonna see transformers
3 and he really wants people to see
transformers 3 and he claims it's gonna
be like Black Hawk Down and really cool
and all that which is funny because
that's what battle Los Angeles looks
like if that movie is actually good at
that point he has to be better than in
beat battle Los Angeles otherwise
transformers 3 is gonna be the movie
that wasn't as good as battle Los
Angeles and now he wants to make that
third one really good so let's get a
model who's never acted in anything in
her entire life he had the building
blocks of a good movie Bay something
tells me you screwed the pooch on that
one I'm just saying I don't think I'm
gonna be like that chick was so good in
the movie she was everything Megan Fox
was not here's what I personally want
from transformers 3 give us some sweet
hardcore Robot action because we all
want that [ __ ] minimize the annoying
parents because they're just stupid I
like them in moderation but since you
can't do moderation Michael Bay don't
have them there's no reason for John
Turturro to be in it the John Turturro
scenes and transformers 1 and a lot of
Transformers 2 was just like a big
stupid comedy written by
five year old plus the fact that all
these people uniting in the same place
for a third time over the odds are not
in their favor that that would happen so
something's got to give you don't have
to have every character return for every
movie sometimes people move on and go
onto other [ __ ] maybe John tutorials
like in Antarctica fishing for ice it's
too late to say get a good actress to
replace Megan Fox cuz you got a model
who hasn't acted ever Optimus Prime
sweet military action and Armageddon
it's robots fighting but we wanted
robots fighting coolest scene in
transformers twos like the forest fight
scene transformers is like the beginning
of transformers one when blackout
transforms just wastes everybody that's
the [ __ ] so give us more scenes like
that in like a city or something which
really sounds like Black Hawk Down which
is what you promised it'll be like I'm
just saying be a man of your word bag in
so many words by admitting that
transformers 2 was crap you've
ultimately come out and said Jeremy's
right and I appreciate that and my fans
appreciate that and my oh so humble ego
can barely take the weight but I will
try to carry that cuz it's my
responsibility and for transformers 3
being a good movie we'll see but I find
it neat that he finally admits that
we're all right and he was wrong and if
you like what you seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more